Hey, Forrest, how come
you've never reviewed
being hit by a car?
It's weird.
Anyway, what's it
like to be pranked?
Oh, see that?
Look at that.
You were so afraid.
That's a great one.
It looks like April Fools' has
come a bit early this year.
What do you think of that?
Nothin'?
Ah, well, here
I go to get pranked.
This should be a fun one, right?
Forrest: At first,
being pranked appeared
to be just the assignment
I needed after
the emotionally exhausting
experience
of vetoing
my ex-wife's request.
But then I realized that
since I can't prank myself,
this had the potential
to be uniquely challenging.
Hi.
Hello, Grant.
Well, I should talk
to you about something.
This is very difficult
in light of recent events,
but I'm just gonna
cut to the chase
and tell you
what I just learned.
What is it?
"Review" has, uh,
been canceled.
What?
Did you just tell me
that "Review" has been canceled?
Afraid so.
No. That can't be true.
No, Grant, Grant.
[ Scoffs ] No.
I know.
They can't do that.
Nobody can do that.
You can't do --
You don't do that.
You can't do that, Grant!
Hey, listen to me.
What you are saying
now cannot happen.
[Bleep] no!
Are you [bleep] kidding me?
I wish I were.
I just [bleep] vetoed
that thing from Suzanne
trying to get me out of there
because you [bleep]
told me to!
[Bleep] no!
Get back on the [bleep] phone,
and you tell them, "No.
If you do this, the host
will [bleep] kill himself.
We're doing more of this.
Absolutely not."
I'm in the middle
of a review right now.
I mean, we're in the middle
of doing this.
[ Laughing ] We're in
the middle of doing it.
Oh.
Grant's prank was a true
masterpiece of the form.
Grant, that was...
Hmm!
That was a little too good.
Oh.
The most impressive thing
about it was that it took me,
a man who was waiting
to be pranked,
completely by surprise.
Okay.
I know that you're doing
a segment
on being pranked right now.
But this is
actually real.
Why would they cancel "Review"?
I feel like an idiot.
Well, it's the ratings.
They're really bad.
Haven't you noticed how few
questions we've been getting?
You're still doing it?
Your ex-wife
asked a question.
That's how few submissions
we're getting.
[ Laughing ]
I want you to know that I did
not take this lying down.
Okay.
Even though they're
bumping me upstairs
to be a vice-president
of the network,
I fought for you.
I guess people just didn't care
for the show as much as we did.
You really thought
it through, too.
My God.
Thank you.
Okay.
[ Laughs ]
This is a very nice touch.
Oh, my God.
The best pranks
involve multiple people
bolstering one another's
ridiculous deceptions.
Hello.
Tina: Hi.
And this was
a truly great prank.
Oh, boy.
We're really sorry.
About what?
About the show
getting canceled.
Ah, yes.
Poor "Review" getting canceled.
What will become
of the two of you?
Well, A.J. got a new show.
Ah.
It's a travel show.
Oh.
Yeah. So she's gonna
actually take us with her
and take us
around the world.
And she's going to pay us.
Yes, got it.
It's kind of amazing.
Yes, that is.
That is.
I don't want to go
around the world.
I don't want to get paid.
I just want to work
for Mr. MacNeil.
It's --
Forrest: Josh endured what must
have been excruciating pain
for the purpose of this joke.
And for that,
I salute him.
What are you doing?
I think he's trying to hug you.
Oh.
As you would in the case
of a cancellation
of the show, yes.
I love you more
than my dad.
Okay, best male
intern in a drama.
[ Sobbing ]
[ Laughing ]
Forrest: My staff had impressed
me in innumerable ways.
But their dedication
to helping me
with my review of being pranked
was unprecedented...
Here we go.
and totally wonderful.
Have you got a farewell speech
for me, Lucy?
Um...
Thank you.
This is actually
the easiest job I've ever had.
Is that right?
Yeah. I've written three
erotic novels
under the name
Beverly LaFontaine
if you want
to check 'em out.
Thank you for
letting me know that.
We'll have to find more
for you to do in the future.
Oh, you're in denial.
Okay.
This should make this
go smoother.
I am not
a very sentimental person,
but, um...
I'm glad you got out
of this dumb show alive.
Mmm, yes.
She's really leaving.
[ Laughs ]
Three days
into this prank,
I began to wonder just
how far this conspiracy
of silliness extended.
Had my ex-wife and son been
roped into the fun, as well?
But there was no way of knowing,
because when I stopped
by their house,
no one was home.
As the week came to a close,
this prank revealed itself
to be fantastically elaborate.
Uh. Oh, God.
[ Laughs ]
This just goes on
and on and on.
[ Fart ]
Oh!
"Now you can review
what it's like to be pranked.
Love, Josh and Tina."
That's a bit of
a hat on a hat.
But Josh and Tina were right.
I could certainly review
what it was like to be pranked.
And it keeps getting better
because look who's not here --
A.J. Gibbs.
She's also playing along,
off to do her
travel show, I guess.
Ah, it is a total delight
to see everyone
in my world
working together to improvise
a kind of a comic play.
Though I did feel
a bit foolish at first,
I mostly feel very fortunate
to be surrounded
by people who care enough
about me and my work
to go to such great lengths.
Now, if I have one criticism,
it's that this prank
was really not
all that believable,
because what kind of a universe
would be cruel enough
to allow "Review"
to be canceled right
after I chose it over my family?
Come on. [ Laughs ]
But all in all,
I give being pranked
five really fun stars.
That's all the time
we have for "Review."
See you next time.